Welcome to 2D game
development with libGDX.
I'm Jeremy, lifelong gamer and
course developer at UDACITY.
>> And I'm James, UDACITY's
game depth curriculum designer.
In this nano degree, you'll learn how to
use the libGDX framework to create games
that run anywhere from your desktop
to web browser to android or iOS.
First, you'll explore the basics of the
game loop and drawing to create icicles.
A game where you control
a character dodging an avalanche.
>> Then for your first project,
you'll create a breakout clone called
Outbreak
>> Next,
you'll learn to direct the complex
orchestra of entities and
interactions that make up a platforming
game featuring our hero, Gigi Gal.
>> And for your second project,
you apply these skills to a tap down
shooter called Space Kerfuffle.
>> There are many ways to have
a career in game development.
You can join an established studio.
Or, if you're interested in
becoming an indie developer,
you'll need to learn how
to monetize your games.
>> The best way you can do that is to
make games that are fun and engaging.
And you'll learn how to
integrate services for ads,
in app purchases, and even leaderboards.
>> Then, you'll learn to use even
spicier features that will really make
your game stand out,
like physics and II.
>> Finally, for your capstone project
you'll use all of these skills to make
a game of your own design.
>> Building games is challenging, but
at least you can always
procrastinate by testing a game.
>> Best of luck in the nano degree.
We can't wait to see
what you come up with.